good morning Hank it's Tuesday several
weeks ago YouTube asked me to be part of
their class of 2020 celebration and I
wanted to share today some of the
resulting video which I made in the
hopes of encouraging students and
teachers and really anyone because I
feel like we could all use a little fuel
hello and congratulations I know it
feels weird done ambiguously celebrate
anything these days with fear and
sadness abounding in every direction but
what you've accomplished is real and
it's important and it's worthy of
celebration I actually have a related
story although I didn't experience
anything like the disruption you're
currently going through I did have a
somewhat unusual graduation when I was a
junior in college I had to take a
semester off because of some mental
health problems so I graduated later
than most of my classmates and I
remember being in the audience watching
them graduate with their caps and gowns
and I was really happy for them but I
also felt this gnawing sense of hurt I
wanted to be celebrating with them and I
couldn't help but feel like I was a
disappointment I figured that when I did
graduate in December somebody would just
mail me my diploma and that would be it
but here's what happened instead one of
my professors at Kenyon College Donald
Rogen conspired with some other
professors and some of my friends to
throw me an unofficial graduation after
finals that semester professor Rogan
gathered us in his home offered a brief
commencement address and had me walk
across the stage of his living room to
accept a fake diploma that he had made
for me it wasn't the college graduation
I had dreamed of but it was still really
meaningful for me in fact I still have
professor Rogen's diploma and I have no
idea where my actual college diploma is
this is a symbol for me of how great
teachers really can change the lives of
their students if you have such teachers
I hope you're able to thank them today
and I hope that you're able to do for
yourselves and for your friends what
Professor Rogan did for me and find ways
to commemorate and celebrate this
achievement before I go I'd like to ask
you to do something I learned from the
children's television host Fred Rogers
you're likely separated from many people
you care about I know I am and you may
be separated from some of the people
whose generosity helped you to achieve
what you're celebrating today friends
family teachers mentors there are so
many P
who loved you up into this moment and
I'd like to ask you to spend one minute
of silence thinking about those people
now I know a minute of silence on the
Internet is a very long time but we can
do this together I'll keep the time
I know many of those people can't be
with you right now
and I'm sure that's very hard maybe
they're locked down somewhere else or
maybe they're not with us anymore but I
want you to know something those people
you were just thinking about they are so
proud of you today
they are so so proud and that's true
whether you graduated this year or not
Hank I'll see you on Friday